we're recording right yeah okay we're
back for a final time you know the
tournament is over
it ended well for one of us
congratulations you have your medal
thanks guys I'm gonna change this to
round nine real quick nice I
spoiler alert did well in my last game
and you're not even showing off your
double trophy yeah yeah okay so yeah
things went really well
I won the round nine game that we
discussed I think at the end of round
eights video and wait wait wait you won
the round nine game well today we
discussed or I mean that we that we're
going to discuss no I mean that um we
mentioned that we might and that allow
me to tie for second place in the
tournament actually tie for first place
get clear second on tiebreaks first
place went to the GM that you played
Ferrari and it crushed me yeah and gave
me a nice little trophy that says local
to which is probably place number two
and then I got a third place trophy for
the Bliss tournament that was um took
place a couple of days ago it was nice
yeah I got sixth place not a trophy but
a certificate for the blitz treatment I
was so unexpected we were at the word
ceremony and there was all in Romanian
and they started calling my name at
first I didn't realize I had won
something
but I won like 70 Romanian late and the
certificate I'm sorry just say I'd no
longer but it was this Romanian
organizer Sava Christensen it was great
a blitz tournament really really nice
guy so yeah yeah this was a great a
great day overall for you now yes yeah
so we'll we'll go over the final round
games I have a tough finish I mean I
started out for now
fala five I was tied for first and I
just ran out of steam and I think people
will see that in this game I just ran
out of fighting spirits yeah but I had a
good opening again like all my games
good openings and then just kind of
finish off certain positions this game
especially the position was so good so
let's get to it and we'll get through
this and then we can see your amazing
finish so I went into the round well I
walked in the tournament hall thinking I
was gonna play the London I saw my
opponent he looked kind of quiet and
somewhat suspicious I thought maybe he
prepared for London so I played c4
surprise and I actually did a little bit
of prep last night like I was just
looking at some of his recent games from
this tournament and I saw he played some
weird line again see forest so I wanted
to to test him but honestly I was still
gonna play the London until I I saw him
at the board so he played e5 Knight c3
now he played a really rare move here
which I've never encountered before but
I was actually expecting this move c5
yeah which looks like a positional
travesty give him that he's weakening d5
for nothing but he had another game the
tournament where he played like knight
c6 g6 Bishop g7 it's one of these like
rivers Botvinnik type setups mm-hmm but
I usually like to do this when I see my
opponent is playing something maybe
offbeat or dubious I like to try and
either a few there punish it or at least
get something fresh and playable so
that's what I attempted to do in this
game I play e3 actually know the move
order is wrong I entered this game
incorrectly I played Knight f3 first but
it transpose as I played Knight f3
knight c6 and 93 so we got to this
position now the best move for black is
to play Knight f6 yeah and then
potentially go into like a reverse time
mana for a reverse Sicilian Colin but I
would be happy there because I play
time on is is back up a tempo through
the temple I would have played a three
here a three nice inviting d5 yeah and
if he doesn't play d5 I might play 95 at
some point with ideas with like B for
potential but he played d6 and it was a
sign that he's being stubborn like he
wants to still achieve this set up with
g6 and Bishop g7 but now I can play the
media t4 it's one of the points of this
early e3 and I looked this up just a few
minutes ago
in the database and white score is very
highly like while over 60%
I forget which database I was using
either Willie chess or like the Masters
database but I think black is already
having some issues here just with the
pawn tension d5 potential yeah he played
Bishop g4 I play d5 force an idle a I
want to show one line yeah he played
Knight b8 I wanted to show just a funny
possibility like let's imagine Nike 7 I
had a cute trick I was gonna play HD 3
I'll say Bishop h5 and then Queen a4
check and the trick is after Queen d7
pretty sure this is the next move should
just be crushing white to move well
maybe it's not crushing but it's still
probably the strongest move maybe five
yeah Knight b5 there's a double threat
of Knight c7 and that take you six and I
think the only waited for him to the
fenders King da da King exactly yeah so
it should be good for light so I was
secretly hoping for something like this
I think Chi Roth Joshi did some lecture
on some idea like this Oh Chester
University remember like watching one of
his videos that's the same like Quinn a
fortnight b5 idea targeting g6 in c7
anyway I thought it was a cute idea
maybe that's one reason he played might
be it's keeping the d6 pawn defendant by
the bishop I play h3 he takes which made
me happy because now now I have the
option of taking with the Jeep on which
I do and I really like the structure I
have the two bishops I have open G file
I have potential on kind of all areas of
the board with the Queen here oh really
well it just looks like a king zinnia
now once you play e4 and you just gave
up the life squared Bishop I guess
that's true I guess I don't have too
much Kings Indian structures yeah it's
like I was thinking my queen wants to
still go to eight four at some points
mm-hmm
try and create some annoyances
like I was imagining here that if he
ever tries like g6 Bishop g7
right then if d6 is left undefended I
have this Queen a fortnight b5 idea
I was also imagining like pushing my H
pawn to h5
I also wanted to get my Bishop to h3
I achieved a lot of these ideas in the
game he played that 5h for this should
be seven I mean this has to be nice for
whites
now I'm not sure if I made the right
decision I played before keaneally which
does allow f4 there is some idea I
wanted to do earlier maybe it's a bit
too extravagant but I wanted to play f4
just to show this that if he takes it
was some kind of positional pawn
sacrifice idea is this the Karpov idea
like the famous game against Kasparov
the end game night versus Bishop I wish
I know what you're talking about I don't
is very so era is like black just plays
like G takes h4 taking a pawn uh-huh and
instead of recapturing with the Jeep on
he just plays like Knight G - oh wow
asking black to take he takes with the
King and then his king is like abled oh
yeah interesting and it's like yeah like
positional pawn sacrifice like this yeah
well yeah in this case it's all about
getting the knight c6 nice with idea
that if he takes I could probably just
take back with Bishop I'm down the pawn
but it's very hard to stop this time the
new fur yeah this looks really nice
alright so I didn't play this because I
thought it looked weird I also thought
maybe you can just play e4 and oh maybe
this was a better shot maybe I can like
me for f3 yeah I think you should be
good and I just didn't want to stack up
on like what I played in the game just
seems simpler Bishop h3 9 h 6e 4 and it
does allow him to close the center but I
get in Qin a forecheck and now he can't
really play Knight d7 he played King f8
if he plays Knight d7
he's completely tied down yeah I'm sure
there's some maybe I just go for
paralysis here like play h5 and Bishop
e6 and black it was just kind of stuck
yeah
eighty-three before so he played King f8
i played h5 and the weird thing about
this game like i know i'm better here
like clearly like black is pretty
restricted but i don't know where i had
an opportunity to like be like clearly
clearly better or like winning better
because i knew i was always slightly
better but he just seemed to keep
surviving keep surviving so maybe you
should be on the lookout for other
things I could have done
he played g5 I take he takes I played
kini to I mean this is the most natural
idea right 9 f7 Bishop d2 and then he
played King g7 which i think is a good
move making sure is rook on h8 is
supported the Jeep on supported so if I
ever try and pressure along the G file
g6 was defended in his Knight g5 in many
cases too so I played there should be
six maybe this wasn't it in accuracy
because he Titan that chief I with tempo
later but Knight g5 is coming anyway so
not entirely sure anyway I'll show that
there's research to take take Knight g5
there's if g4 I'm still happy right like
I have the H file black is slow to
develop on the queenside the only square
for the knight on b8 is to go to a six
and then I just wanted to break through
with b4 and play a three-night c7 and
then I realized well maybe I should just
play b4 here I didn't play before I
realized some other idea in the position
to bring my Queen to the H file and
maybe this was a problem maybe I should
just play d4 yeah before looks i wasn't
sure like b6 right
and he just coming holds on is actually
very similar to the structure I had in
my game as well with E 5 C 5 I feel like
I mean if you just play Queen C 6 like
how does black move ah that's true
C 6 where is nice he had some idea to
play Knight EA to f6 and my bishop
actually kind of runs out of the squares
right but maybe I was also a bit
confused like when I do play d4 it's
like a attractive plan I don't really
want to take on c5 because then he can
take back with the D pawn and get the d6
square right but then you well you try
to push a 4 a 5 there is one plan that I
think is pretty interesting where you
keep the pawn on b4 and maybe put your
Queen on like b3 and then try to push a
4 a 5 without taking on c5 just leave
all the tension but the problem is here
the night is just very ready to come to
like a 65 and so as soon as you play for
is just gonna take and want that night
there but you know that actually might
be playable like you still have this a4
a5 break well the problem is like if I
ever play for a4 he could possibly play
a5 and just close things down but maybe
that's good maybe I stick a knife on b5
and then target the a5 fun yeah it also
depends if he's gonna play 98 in this
position because then his Knight is
further away that's true and I think
yeah I mean actually I feel like yeah
maybe your advantage is not that big
it's possible I just overestimated my
advantage this game even though it
visually looks great it looks really
good
I'll show it happened I played Queen d1
I thought that like Queen g1 Queen h2
it's hard to stop he played rugby eights
Queen g1 then he played Queen's Yeates
he was being like overcautious and now
again i think i should play before I
started with queen h2 queen eight shades
I just wanted to repeat I was expecting
Queen g8 back here but he didn't play
Queen G if he played Queenie 8 which is
a good move he's preparing b5 now right
and then I took a long think he offered
me a draw somewhere around here because
we could repeat but then I went for
before I was trying to somehow
complicate things and then he was very
calm he just played b6 I was thinking it
would have been really interesting if he
takes and plays b5 yeah I'm sure I don't
think I mentioned this but he was a low
rated player he's like 2020 100 typical
types of opponents for me this
tournaments and sometimes when there's a
big rating differential the the weaker
player the lower rated player in this
case doesn't necessarily want to take
risks like this yeah but I thought maybe
watt could be playing for something here
this is sharp can you play c5 here I was
looking at some c5 idea to deflect the
bishop from defending the knight yeah
trying to work out some calculations
I take because when I have g6 ideas yes
thing you just take on see father's like
Tay like Bishop d7
or Bishop f5 might be better yeah Bishop
f5 with them Bishop e7 oh yeah this is
so Bishop f5 if there should be seven I
have d6 right it could get messy though
oh yeah I'm so tired right now this
position just makes my head yeah so
let's save this for another time yeah
that's exactly so he just played b6 and
then I repeats following the advice that
then Feingold always repeats and then I
trade Queens thinking that maybe I can
grind down this endgame I have two
bishops and I have some play on the
Queen side and pieces are kind of stuck
and then I think I handled this very
badly like I put no pressure on him I
try to but I I overlook some moves and
then it was just a draw first of all I
probably shouldn't have taken on c5 I
think probably I should leave the
tension I took on c5 because I wanted
him to make the choice what to take back
with right but now I'm realizing that I
should just leave the pawn on b4 there's
no rush I should optimize I should
probably optimize my Knights and start
with something like 91 probably bring
the knight to d3 and maybe even like
trying lock that came to a4 there there
is some entry point on the Queen side
yeah King definitely goes to a4 force
him to play a six exactly and then you
always have ideas yeah yeah and if I had
I think I was tired like okay of course
now I'm tired but during the game I was
tired I just had little energy I wasn't
playing for any prize I was just really
playing for really not to embarrass
myself further yeah
which is not great motivation so yeah
it's a hard kind of mental state to play
in but looking back on it I mean I mean
I if this were a blitz game I probably
would have played like the right the
right idea in the heat of the game I
took on c5 you played the right move
t-take c5 I could still do the same idea
in 91 bring the knight to d3 bring the
King to a4 but I played just such a bad
move your a4 just allowing him to close
everything up play five now I have no
more entry point with the king for some
reason a5 just escaped me like I've for
some reason I thought I was gonna play
a5 and create pressure a 594 right yeah
so I have no room to attack the backward
pawn in b6 I really wanted to play d6 in
this position okay I played King g3 in
the game but if I play d6
it's a positional pawn Zach I think he
has to take on d5
because 98 runs into some like Bishop
see it this should be 7 I was
calculating this I probably would have
gone for this if he doesn't have this
next move like c4 c4 yeah because then
my King can't get in well and c4 it
looks like a weakness but it's just wait
so what is he do you just keep going I
thought he has time to like do stuff and
maybe Bishop c5 yeah he's gonna put the
bishop on d4 and it's it's hard to win
this pawn alright and I thought it might
be risking losing the position like he
can bring the Knight to d6 yeah yeah
anyway that's what I I mean I considered
so I'll just quickly show the end of the
game I play king d3 Bishop d6 92 he
played enough seven bishops e3 I'm going
for some I take a four cheapo
he plays the g5 and played Bishop h5 he
played nine aged six and then I played
Knight c1 and offered him a draw I mean
maybe I could have tried to grind
further but it just seems like uh it
just seems like a fortress for black I
didn't see any like breakthrough he's
gonna put the king on a six nine and a
six and maybe there's some potential
idea to like walk the King to g4 but
then I thought his Knight comes in and I
have to worry about like night at sea
294 ideas yeah so I figured that given
my mental state there if I played on to
try and win there there'd be a real
possibility that I would over push right
like yesterday like this this rook a one
move we had just allowing my opponent
some chances to win so I was actually
content with a draw he he defended well
I think from a suboptimal position yeah
yeah but again like with all my games so
far I'm gonna have to go back check and
see what the engine recommends what
exactly my mistakes were because I feel
like my mistakes over this tournament
were in some ways related in terms of
getting some maybe not huge advantage
but clear clear edge and not being able
to maximize it which is tough and
especially being the stronger player or
the high rated player in most of these
games opponents are always happy with
the draw yeah so it's sometimes hard to
to play for a win right you have to keep
yeah anyway maybe I can learn from from
your play well my my technique was not
not great I mean this game was a hundred
and twelve votes ooh yeah I knew it was
this long yeah actually I think it was
the last game to thin
the tournament hmm so I was playing it's
actually funny last year I was on board
one in the last round in this tournament
and I also had close to a hundred move
game also the last game in the
tournament and I drew I was playing the
person in clear face it's pretty
upsetting yeah anyway let's take a look
yeah so I'm playing um FM here Catalan
Nero you hope I'm pronouncing that right
and nice guy actually we met him during
the the blitz tournament then had yeah
and he's around 23 70 and he's already
got his I am norm so he's he's a pretty
strong player mm-hmm
we got the Kings Indian do you know did
he gain rating from the stringent not
sure I can check cuz like he's on the
verge of becoming an item right he just
needs to make it to 2400 let's see
so he's gaining losing a bunch of
poising 16 points Wow yeah and I thought
he had a good event oh yeah because you
drew some lower rated players I guess
this makes me concerned to check me high
rating so after the summer is done
hopefully I can make up for it that's
turn minutes but we'll see all right
okay well he going for the classical
main line and which actually a little
bit of a surprise because he hasn't
played this much mm-hmm so it was pretty
clear he had prepared something against
Knight a six because you've had games in
the database I see yeah yeah I've played
a bunch of games in that a six a few
with 97 and a couple would like a 5 and
96 and I don't know I mean it's
definitely it's not the most pleasant
feeling in the world when you know they
have something prepared but I have a lot
of experience in these positions and so
I you know it's a great choice for the
last round game so he's half a point
behind going into the round and so he
needs to play for a win in order to get
any chance of prize money so I was it's
actually a good situation to be in
yeah it's great for me because I'm half
a point behind first place and with the
win I can tie for first with a draw
depending on how tiebreaks go could be
in here from like third to six so Owen
was nice okay so c6
he pushes d5 and we get this line that
probably done a couple of videos and
with this position this is very unusual
Kings Indian because it's like II five
c5 the bishop is stuck on h4
and is hard for block to push f5 because
of the pin and and because of White's
pressure okay he plays 91 it's the main
line here right black normally plays h5
but I smelled a rat so I played Knight
age six
it is also playable it basically just
kind of a different move order because
usually the night will come back to f7
and then black plays h5 anyway
is still some sort of preparation there
well this line has been part of my
repertoire for mm-hmm like two years and
I have several games with h5i so he he
likely prepared this one because after
96 he started thinking and so he wasn't
sure exactly what the the plan should be
for white mm-hmm
okay he plays a three now the I mean
this is definitely the most sensible
plan in the position just putting the
nine on d3 playing B for Brooke b1 and
that's kind of what a six to nine f7 and
actually there's a funny trap if he
plays Bishop g4 here just trading off
the light squared Bishop it looks like
positionally white is winning but well I
can just take five no and I think yeah
is there f5 here just a move that came
to mind
I think this position is just like it's
actually not that bad for black because
the darker bishop kind of gets stuck out
on the UH can you play like h5 g 5h for
nobody oh we can take but it feels like
you should trap the bishop somehow yeah
maybe some some tricks I'm not sure but
anyways
he kind of just sticks to normal stuff
93 I mean I don't know maybe Bishop g4
is it's good or maybe I should just play
h5 immediately Bishop d7 B 4 B 6 this is
all pretty normal route b1 + h5 ok so
now I am turning g5h 4 and why is a
choice between H 3 and F 3 if F 3 then
black can get the bishop to h6 which is
kind of nice
Bishop usually comes back to F 2 and F 5
mm-hmm and so this is like a very very
slow-moving Kings Indian compared to
like the Mar del Plata lines with just
like the races the Kings side attacks
acting because the bishop on H 4 is a
real nuisance but it's also usually very
helpful on the Queen side and without it
it's very difficult for white so to
break through so he plays H 3 which is
another way to deal with with G 5 and
now I can't really do this because I'll
just here I will suffer on the lights
worse now Bishop g4 comes
yeah there's no good great and it's just
terrible
and if I play f5 then I mean my queen on
it like be naughty 8 and then f5 he
always just takes and the inch drive
pawn is hanging so it's difficult for
both sides here and we both kind of have
to make waiting moves Bishop h6 Rick b2
Queen e7 rook e1 King h8 and we were
both just like very very calmly
improving our position but he was
spending a lot of time here so I was I
was growing more and more confident okay
here I play rook C I think this is kind
of a critical moment now I'm potentially
threatening to take on before and the c4
pawn is hanging so he kind of has to
deal with this he played night b5 I
think it's pretty reasonable hitting a 7
I backed up and then he makes a pretty
serious mistake here with Queen a4 I
mean looks like he's putting a lot of
pressure but I found in these positions
black has all kinds of these like maybe
5 Queen a4 it just gets into trouble
especially if it's pinned so 97 yeah I'm
not sure exactly what he overlooked here
but the problem with Queen takes a 7
well you guys can pause your video try
to figure it out I think it's a pretty
pretty thematic little combo I'm so
sleepy right now I'm trying not to cheat
- all right trying to hide them to taste
but there's no it's not a no it's not ok
oh it's true can't even cheat its
thematic overnight 85 wait wait wait oh
we can take on B 5 and then take on d5
yeah we definitely take on b5 - hangers
Queen or you know unprotected I guess we
have work aid - and then somehow Oh 98
and then yeah then Queen gets trapped
okay which is very nice I had one game
that was very similar except the
difference was it was a line like this
but his Queen wasn't trapped he had a
square hmm and we like both overlooked
it and had he found it would have been
like yeah it wouldn't like +4 because
I'd give it up material but this was
this one is working yeah so you can't
take the pawn and I'm turning a six now
exactly so he took on c5 he passed - I
took on b5 d c5 and then I get the
struck leg and you're talking about you
have a six or no I did actually but I it
looked so unclear to me during the game
if he took some b6 here takes and like
Queen a seven or something I was trying
to make this work but um he's in
big-time trouble at this point and I
just like gotcha did what's weird yeah
yeah you want to keep things under
control yeah initiatives on his side so
I well I was very happy with the
position that we got I was very much
looking forward to playing this I saw
the this is a round with my game
finished I was I saw like your knight
coming to d6 and it's just so pleasant
yeah looks it looks really nice right
the point is to just keep the Queen side
down and you know get this huge blockade
and then finally push g5h for and then G
for mm-hmm and then just completely roll
on the kingside um and that's kind of
what happened I mean the position like
essentially just played itself and he
held on for as long as he could but um I
just kind of slowly build up on the G
file again I'm using the only open file
in the position okay he played this
probe g3 I think kind of out of
desperation he wants to run in Bishop h3
I simply back up and I just have this
huge pressure on the key file okay
finally we trade the Knights this was
pretty much inevitable he put the bishop
on c4 I took on g3 now if Bishop takes
g3 I think he just gets mated I probably
can play like this ship f4 oh yeah yeah
so I felt like this should be losing so
he took this way which is a very sad I
mean the amazing thing is like I
couldn't win this middle game I had to
spend 80 moves in an endgame trying to
convert but yeah I found the right plan
like bringing the rooks to the H file
and now he's he's very I mean extremely
passive here I mean this is just this is
a reasonable position I think mm-hmm
like Bishop do you wanna push c4 so
principle of two weaknesses like all of
his pieces are thinking up C pawn starts
running I want to come in with my queen
I mean I thought it was just like over
here and it is I mean it's - seven -
eight
rook c2 rook c7 Queen a3 Queen F - I
took the pawn I think I regret this
decision now is spending some time here
trying to figure out how to break
through I mean it the position looks so
good for black can you just like play
rook CH 7 and move the bishop yeah I I
really wanted to make this move because
yeah if he takes the pawn or just back
up and then when
material right and it's game with your
queen spitting out three yeah and Queen
f3 is hanging but I thought he would
play the only move Bishop d1 just
getting the Bishop off of the attack and
if I play Bishop d7 he can move the
Queen like Queen f3 or something I don't
know but this is completely winning for
black we can take the pawn yeah he just
has nothing when you have this looming
pressure like yeah his rook is stuck I
probably probably do exactly yeah
cousin you win the second rank yeah I
mean it's just it's just b5 yeah
everything is hanging so I I just but
see at this point I think board one had
had finished mm-hmm and they drew so
there's crusher yeah and so now if I win
this game then I'm tying for first
guaranteed the game next to me they also
drew at some point no it's hard when
first places on the line money is on the
line
yeah I was it you to play that happy I
was just feeling like extremely nervous
I mean like and my pointer has been in
time trouble for less like 20 moves I'm
still in like 20 minutes on the clock
right it's is weird my strategy in this
type of situation is to just try and
like take as many deep breaths as
possible feel like it's a good way to
like calm yourself down and think that's
why it helps to meditate like if you
meditate every day like you can that
mindset you play just staying calm yeah
I feeling self-aware and I've definitely
felt that in some games when I felt like
my technique was good despite being in
time trouble or something but this was
not one of those games okay so I took
the pawn he plays rugby one now already
he's like threatening to trap my Queen
it's like what am I doing here
yeah c3 okay I mean this position is
still winning I still should go to HSN
but I felt like this is fine because now
I have rigged d2 and he doesn't have
racks eh I rigged c7 is nothing rig d2
is coming it looks fantastic but he has
Queen c2 and if I play like Queen d4
trying to get out of the green trade
rookie
one comes and it's just suddenly I've
given him this weird counterplay maybe
Rick see a check at some point you know
and some some random chances so I
realize I'm actually just forced to
trade Queens which I was very disturbed
about given my position like three moves
ago but I realize I should still be
winning this I'm a pawn up all my pieces
are better this bishops on each - yeah
like he has so many weaknesses this
should be technical and so I actually
wasn't so miffed at this point
mmm Bishop e6 rugby one we trade and
rook h7 I think an important move
stopping work c7 and so my point is just
I want to bring the rook to d7 Rick d4
maybe maybe even put the Bishop on c5 it
looks completely winning King G - Bishop
e3 rooks e6 and here I think I I
definitely this is where I just messed
up I should have given this check which
I you know wanted to do urgently okay he
has to play King f3 and then had I just
done a little bit of calculation I would
have realized that I can just play
Bishop c5 here and just get a very
comfortable or Bishop d4 either way oh
because he can't take on a 6 because
like Bishop Bishop f1 yeah wow I think
this is findable right like Bishop is
obviously for trapped oh you take on b5
yeah okay I mean like yeah I think I
should have found I mean this was
already on my radar I was watching the
game at this point and when he played
Rick c6 the only move I saw was rookie 7
but that's what I play it's like I was
just trying to keep it simple right but
it allows him to trade exactly yeah you
don't want to turn off that terrible
Bishop I mean I went for this because
the resulting end game is still clearly
better for black because he has two
pawns fixed on light squares right and
but I mean I don't know it's like
it could have been better it was just
the nerves I mean it's not that
complicated to calculate this line right
so there's a bit of a miss anyways he
trades off I bring in my king and it was
just amazingly difficult to make
progress in this position I mean it's
crazy
now so we're so we're on move 62 it took
you 50 more move and most of those moves
were spent doing absolutely nothing to
be honest I mean it looks great for
black because any trade if we trade
rooks it's a game over I Viking on c5
Bishop c4 no counter play if we trade
bishops it's also really bad for him
because as b5 pawn is this weakness
just put the rook on c5 and yeah I'll
just play like you know in this position
I would play ricky 6 slowly force him to
back up King v6 rook c7 again no counter
play but the problem is I just can't
force a trade of pieces here and as rook
is so active it's always starting to go
to a-1 and hit the a 7 point mm-hmm so I
I foots around a lot and sometimes
that's what you got to do with increment
like play quickly to build up enough
time to find some idea or just play
practically yeah for your opponent to
and this before some opportunity I had
caught up to him so we're both just like
add I mean maybe three or four minutes
but making every move about 30 seconds
but yeah I was trying to make at least
relatively simple moose to gain some
time but I still couldn't figure out
like how to improve and then I got my my
rook on eight which I just didn't know
how else to I will still play the
position now I wish I had just kept my
rook on the seventh rank and kept kept
on moving but anyways we keep
maneuvering okay what's his rook on a1
now I start moving my bishop around wait
when he played rook t1 check can you
play king c5 or is that you just keeps
checking you yeah I think the problem is
thinking like king before
once they go too far he'll play Ric f1
and then you want to win the pond like
Bishop d7 oh yeah yeah this is then you
can keep checking you like rook b1 and
you you have to go back to d6 yeah yeah
yeah that's annoying it's hard to it's
hard to do anything here yeah I think
objectively this position is way the
same line the same line after rook f1
and so instead of Bishop d7 Bishop c4
but then checked right
and Bishop OH Bishop b3 Bishop d1 yeah
yeah I wanted to play like a5 even a5
doesn't work okay yeah it's annoying
yeah I mean the bishop I need to is just
very solid right and but okay I keep and
it's hard when you're the one who needs
to prove something and all white has to
do is wait right
yeah and he just like just piles on this
a pawn right so I have some ideas I can
bring my king - b7 for example but then
I always have to watch out for Bishop c4
Bishop d5 I realize I have one idea
where if I can attack the Jeep on with
tempo and then play rook g7 mm-hmm then
I can get back to the seventh rank right
and so I start vacating the the seventh
ring to try and make this happen okay so
a lot of maneuvers and he thinks I'm
just doing nothing just like circus
efficie
but I've already kind of come up with
the idea never played Bishop b3 I
stopped Rick do you want Chuck mm-hm and
then I pull back thinking like okay now
he's just gonna repeat probably he
should give like rook d3 check and then
right for you to block the seventh rank
and then and then go and then I have to
just keep keep looking for something
mm-hmm
but he played rook a one I got rook g8
now he could definitely take but okay at
least the position has changed and I can
I don't know put my rook on b3 mm-hmm
maybe king c5 yeah I'm making progress
so so he plays King f2 our g7 and good
job yeah and then I think actually this
was the real mistake rooks you want I I
don't
understand why he didn't give this check
maybe maybe he was worried that I just
come in and this time I'm gonna stay
because I can just go to like be to and
he can't it's interesting like going all
the way yeah cuz he can't attack
anything maybe he was worried about this
because after Rick see one I get the
move I really want to get which is Rick
c7 mm-hmm because now I'm holding
everything and I'm ready to just come in
at any time c5 so yeah I made like a
bunch of these maneuvers okay so now I
got a lot of confidence but the problem
is we're encroaching on the 50 move role
when was the last pond the last capture
was about 30 moves ago back here and
there there's been no pawn move since no
pawn moves so taking on g1 well let's
move 57 oh so you still have until so I
have like 20 ways yeah 23 yeah but it's
gonna take me a lot of time to with
everything right and and for summary
decide on this plan to go put my king on
g5 mm-hmm I thought it made sense I'm
just like I'm always ready to push out
five and I'm potentially 13 king g4 but
he gets his rook to h8 and now he can be
very annoying from behind actually I
can't play King g4 just rook g8 but this
gives me a chance to improve my rook
again and I put it on a three mm-hmm now
I'm active and defending nice but now
this is move 92 so I have like 15 moves
left it's true yeah your pawns can't
really advanced and
okay I realize okay if if nothing else
at some point I should be able to play
f5 and also I do have this new plan of
putting my rook on a5 and then just like
weaseling my way back and then trying to
get the bishop to e8 or like here
bringing the King to e7 Bishop d7 wreck
a5 to do that before 108 cutting a close
fortunately for me he actually ends up
blundering rook a to check I played rook
a 5
and he plays Bishop c4 so now it's
blocked to play and basically win and
okay I'm trying not to cheat yeah
and win yes strong word this is it
wait is easy for just your okay three as
a candidate move ah
rook a3 Bishop d3 f5 mm-hmm this bishops
pinned and so yeah basically I kind of I
kind of like triangulated my rook by
accident to be honest like cuz here he's
not pin so I don't have a thought as you
want his King on III right so I I play
tricky to check and then if I play rook
a3 he would see the threat and just play
Kings - but I haven't even noticed that
five yet uh-huh or at least that would
be so strong so I play brick a5 just to
go after the pawn
he passed efficiency for accidental
triangulation that's great yeah okay
that'll be the title and then and now
Chuck he can't defend both bonds mm-hmm
so there should be three f5 now the
point is if he takes
okay now rook d3 would be just colossal
blunder just trading into a King and
pawn endgame with an extra pawn that's
just dead lost because he has the
outside passed pawn and his king is um
yes he said just in time actually I was
calculating some lines because sometimes
block yeah he gets to a7 and it's the
wrong position that's nice
right and I don't even have the draw
because the fifth-ranked role he just
takes to pulling up no matter what so
yeah I can definitely still lose this
but of course I I just have before in
this musician and winning a piece in the
game so he's forced to and fe4 is just a
huge threat he's forced to play king d2
now I got a second pawn and I can take
on g3 but I just thought III is a lot
stronger mm-hmm
King d1 and I gave a check plate rook a
to people a trick c3 I missed this move
I was like okay good point back to a1
and trade yeah and this is a pretty
easily winning he just has
not enough counter play with the jeep on
e3 pawn is too strong it's very hard to
attack it b5 is constant weakness so I
mean I think this is winning any number
of ways now again I do have to be
careful I don't trade in to a bad end
game though this could still be lost but
this one is actually this one is good as
I can come from behind uh and so I'll
just get the b5 point as soon as he gets
the a 7-point interesting and I think I
calculated something like this during
the game but I just thought like why
didn't you wanna yeah yeah not not like
this too many games have gone wrong
right hits so I'm like I'm winning this
just straight forward so I improve the
King give the check and it's very very
on but now I come into f3 forcing the
trade when my king is just a lot more
active guys before I can already play
Bishop f3 here I just played here sure a
three and he resigned because we trade
and my pawn is a lot closer
so yeah 112 moves it's a lot of moves
that was that ya know last year I'd it
was a similar game I was like up a pawn
trying to win but I just didn't win it
was so painful but I I know the feeling
like when you when you grind so harder
than you win it's like it's so
satisfying oh it was incredible I mean
especially cuz you know in the middle of
the game after I had kind of let him
completely off the hook you know maybe
like this position or my rook on a yeah
you had to win this game a few times
yeah definitely I mean at this point I I
was just like just so upset with myself
for allowing him to reach this but one
thing I kind of learned how to do I feel
like in the last year so it was just
like forget the past and just keep
fighting that's what I need to do right
now yeah just like accept that I made a
series of colossal mistakes and you're
just like well this is the position we
let's keep trying to win and yeah that
was good to tie for first place second
place on untie breaks and the the FISC
open yeah
good finish I want to thank everyone for
watching these videos I've been getting
a lot of comments more comments and I
can keep up with right I'll try and
reply to people we have another
tournament coming up in like three or
four more days yeah not too far in Spain
and we're flying out the day after
tomorrow or actually tomorrow because
today is tomorrow all right past
midnight now yeah so let's keep this
brief
I just want to thank everyone for
watching and engaging and if you guys
want to support Costilla you can do so
in the description you can buy his book
on the open Sicilian or you can become a
patron on patreon and get access to all
his annotated games I don't have
anything like that yet
but maybe I'll be inspired I should
probably start annotating my game yeah
have a good nights or good day wherever
you are